The Joe Rogan Experience and in the FTX
case how much of it was getting
celebrities to endorse the platform it's
huge this is what I wanted to say like
the more I study this stuff and you
start to have repeat occurrences like I
just cover stuff all the time and you
see Echoes of the same thing I just had
somebody just a couple days ago I was
interviewing for this for this news
scheme we're looking at it and he said
you know I never understood how Bernie
Madoff got people because it seems so
Preposterous and then I fell for
something very similar and what I
noticed with all of these things the
threat is you believe you know it's kind
of too good to be true but the social
proof is overwhelming and it overwhelms
your kind of like alarm Bells so the
social proof is a combination of things
so first of all it's like it's this guy
who drives a Toyota so you go like well
why does he need to scam me if he's
driving a Toyota right then it's like
which Sam bankman free did then it's
like okay Tom Brady backs him well Tom
Brady's got to have some guys who are
looking into this and then it's like
well BlackRock backed him well BlackRock
definitely has some guys who looked into
it right it's Sequoia Capital they said
he was uh might be one of the first like
trillionaires or whatever like like he's
such a great entrepreneur they think
he's such a genius I actually it might
have been uh one of the a1z guys or uh
uh I'm blanking on the name right now
but a1z what is that no no I'm sorry uh
I'm blanking on it's this famous I've
got to remember it right after I get out
of here it's one of the famous
um like uh investment funds
they invested in a bunch of nft projects
Mark and reason I think
is the guy who runs it
hmm
Jamie's looking it up I thought I knew
it off top of my head and now I don't
want to say the wrong one a16c a16 A1C
a16z I can't it was one of those Sequoia
a616z one of them wrote this glowing
review of Sam basically saying he's
going to be one of the first
trillionaires
um so all these guys basically a lot of
these people backed Sam with the highest
endorsements and so if you're just an
average person you're thinking well how
much more due diligence can I do than
all these other guys all these other
guys buy into him right and like and
then they themselves are kind of also
looking at each other being like well
that guy did it like why it's the
hottest deal around right uh Kevin
O'Leary's in so so you kind of think
you're swimming safely with like other
Savvy investors
and that's what ultimately gets you to
buy in Bernie Madoff is very similar I
mean he was uh you know really well
regarded in Wall Street so when people
invested with him they didn't they knew
the like returns were insane but it
wasn't like he was some random
fly-by-night guy he was well respected
in the Wall Street space people thought
he might take over the SEC after like
the current person had stepped out they
thought he was going to take it over
like he's one of the leaders at the
NASDAQ I mean he was one of the go-to
guys and so you thought well I invest
with Bernie like I can't lose it's like
almost you know betting on the house
like if The House Always Wins right so
when FTX was taking off it just seemed
like everyone who was a someone was
backing him
so then it was okay and then I think a
lot of these people deferred to their
other friends
they're all saying it's okay let me put
money in and it's just a huge case study
that just because other people fall for
something doesn't mean you're safe like
you have to do
I hate to say do your own research
because that's something you overused
like scammy phrase It's actually such
like a phrase like that you know it's
almost let me say this if it's too good
to be true if they're offering market
returns that you want to believe in you
go man I want to believe this is real
don't invest like that's a bad idea
people were calling though just
like they were calling they were there
was a few people that were wary that
were calling on Bernie Madoff
and there was there was a few people
that were standing out and saying this
none of this makes sense right
and who were those people
so there were a few people
um there was
a Matt Levine interview with uh Sam
Bateman for he didn't call him a fraud
outright but he's like hey it seems like
you're in the Ponzi business and
business is good
whoa and what did he say to that he's
like well you know like think of it like
a box and you know you tell a bunch of
investors you know hey if you put money
in this box we can get some money out we
can give you this yield he starts
explain like this thing that sounds
exactly like a Ponzi scheme and so
ultimately Matt Levine's like uh yeah
this doesn't really make a lot of sense
but again it stopped short of this is a
fraud because you know no one knew
there's a bunch of backing so I made a
video at the time being like this crypto
CEO just
describes a Ponzi scheme and that video
has aged so well because it's like
people like oh it was all true
um but like but people were outright
calling it a fraud like Mark cohotis
he's a famous short seller
um he was calling that a fraud early I
have a buddy of mine
um he goes by Dirty Bubble media on
Twitter he's like one of the Anon
Twitter accounts he was calling it a
fraud